the desperate search is underway for
three people believed to be trapped deep
inside an abandoned West Virginia coal
mine four people were reported missing
on Saturday one of them emerged from the
mine on Monday night he told
investigators the other three are still
alive inside the mine chip Reid is near
the mine in Whitesville West Virginia
chip good morning
well good morning the search for the
three missing people is expected to
resume later this morning in the
meantime they've been pumping fresh air
into the mine and standing water out of
the mine but they fear time could be
quickly running out family and friends
on Tuesday waited anxiously for updates
about 25 year-old Kayla Williams 31 year
old Erika Treadway and 21 year old Cody
Beverly investigators believe the
missing trio is inside an inactive mine
in the heart of West Virginia's coal
country I just did my water tank I can't
believe she went in there Tyler Treadway
is Erica's brother I mean it's just
mind-boggling you don't know what the
conditions are you could hit a bad puck
of the air without even knowing it I
mean it's just dangerous Treadway
Beverly Williams and a fourth person 43
year old Eddie Williams were reported
missing late Saturday on Sunday
investigators discovered the group's ATV
near the entrance of Rock House Pelt and
mine and launched a rescue team the
following night Eddie Williams came out
of the mine safely on his own and told
investigators the location of the three
remaining people inside Governor Jim
Justice ordered additional resources
including the National Guard to help
with the search usually these things end
up not very good and so we still got
some real heavy lifting to get to a good
outcome here the rock house pelton mine
has been inactive for two years
trespassers often explore closed mines
in this poverty-stricken state for
abandoned materials including copper
wiring it's just a dangerous place is
being known she goes
please just if your carrier sir you have
other rings you think going in a man
just don't do it the company that owns
the mine says it is cooperating in the
search you know that dangers of coal
mines are well-known in this area just
down the road a little bit as a memorial
to the 29 coal miners who died in the
Upper Big Branch mine disaster eight
years ago
bianna it is a race against the clock
we'll be following this story closely
chip thank you